We have a confession and 20 eyewitnesses wounds all over the place.
And drug test is clear.
No history of mental illness,
everything except for why
did you hear her say anything?
It's like choose someone else.
He didn't try to stop or a mind plays,
tricks.
He see things aren't there.
Tell us anything.
Whatever he can
please welcome to the stage Jessica Biel
have a seat
and we just watched episode one.
Everyone is here.
Uh,
I want to quickly touch on the actual murder scene cause I saw the whole
audience squirm and again bite their nails and do all sorts of things.
Is that the normal reaction that you get from this?
Yeah,
I haven't seen actually haven't watched the show with like many big audiences
before,
you know,
really?
Well,
it's rare I think to have a television show that you get to screen like this.
It's new.
Like you know,
just went to the Tribeca film fest last year,
but that's a new thing.
You know,
usually they are bringing films there.
You're not usually bringing shows there.
So I haven't seen this more than a few times with a larger crowd.
But yes,
it's always a bit of a cringe moment because it comes out of nowhere,
which is the idea,
right?
Is the idea that this person is just kind of,
um,
kind of blacking out and having this sort of a attack almost.
And yeah,
everybody cringes and it's over really fast,
which is kind of another part of the whole idea that when violence occurs in
life,
it doesn't always,
it doesn't always have this long dramatic experience.
It's like boom,
and it's done and you'd,
no one even knows what's happened.
So what was the,
what was the impetus to screen it at festivals?
Because you said it's a new thing,
right?
Well,
for the festivals,
a new thing,
I mean,
um,
I think only last,
sorry,
the,
the year we were,
which was last year,
so the year before that,
I feel like it,
that's the first time that that Tribeca film festival started screening shows.
So for the film festivals,
I believe it's kind of a new thing.
So when you're doing a TV show and then you go to a,
you get to go to a film festival.
First of all,
it's kind of surprising and exciting and then you go and you,
you see the show that you've been making but you,
you've never expected to see it on a huge screen.
You'd expect it to just be on TV,
small.
No,
these are just big TVS.
I know it's different.
It's,
it's just seems different somehow.
Does that mean that you filmed the pilot a long time ago and then you just
picked up two through eight recently?
Yeah,
not long ago.
We
filmed it in the fall.
I think it was the fall.
You,
okay,
good.
I guess what I'm asking is,
is normally,
you know,
you film a pilot,
it gets green lit,
you have to take a screen it and whatnot,
see if there's interest and then it may or may not ever air.
Did you go into it knowing you would make the full eight okay.
No,
we did what you just said.
So we,
we developed the material we got,
I'm a writer on board,
Derek Simons who then wrote the pilot and wrote the Bible for what the,
you know,
what the show would look like,
not necessarily how many episodes it would be because we didn't quite know it
can change when when you eventually sell it to the right place and they kind of
have a lot of opinions about,
you know,
is it,
is it eight,
is it 10 is it only,
is it like a two hour thing two nights in a row,
you know,
whatever.
So we pitched,
we,
we wrote the pilot and then we pitched it around and um,
USA was interested and so they,
they basically that's when they bought the,
sorry.
So then they gave us the money to film the pilot.
Wendy's important.
That's what we needed.
Right.
Money's important sometimes.
And then we showed them the pilot and then they picked up the rest of the
seasons.
So it's possible we would have just shot the pilot and no one ever saw it again.
Huh?
Cause I was reading a two through eight.
If this is an eight part mini series for those of you who don't figure out what
I was talking about already,
um,
you know what the end will be,
you know,
you're not going to a season two,
right?
Or William?
No,
not necessarily.
Well,
I mean,
television is so cool.
Like this is what the idea was sort of like,
could be an anthology series.
So you could,
I mean,
what we want to do with season one is we will,
we will close the case.
Okay.
So you're not going to be season two going,
oh,
I still have to wait for the,
get the answer.
We're going to close out this case and you're gonna understand what happened.
We're going to give you all the answers season too.
You know,
if bill is interested,
Bill Pullman,
I'm talking about obviously,
um,
he can take on a new case.
Um,
and you know,
I don't want to give away what the ending's going to be,
but there is a possibility that maybe my character could be involved in some
way.
Um,
but I don't think that's really giving away much necessarily.
Also know that you're involved in this case.
Yes,
I'm definitely involved in this case,
but,
or you know,
you could,
you could recast the whole thing like I'm a detectives,
right.
Or American horror story,
you know,
just or put characters in other positions.
So you if you could do a lot of things.
Yeah.
And you would be interested in that from the executive producer standpoint.
Well,
yeah.
Not from the acting stand.
Well from both,
but I mean,
yeah,
definitely from the producer standpoint,
I would love my actors to come back.
Okay.
So this is the first time.
Is this the first time you've executive executive produced anything or,
or is this new and old hat for you?
Well,
I,
I did,
uh,
I produced a film with my producing partner,
Michelle purple in my small little tiny company called iron ocean just this past
year called,
um,
the book of love.
Did A,
we produce a small short film.
And so get my,
this and my first television producing.
And how was it,
how is it different for you starring in it and producing it?
Well,
it's just kind of double duty.
You know,
I have to wear a couple of hats,
but definitely when I'm,
when I'm working on onset on,
on the days I'm working on set,
we have a really good team around us.
My,
like I mentioned before,
my producing partner Michelle and Charlie [inaudible] is another one of our
producers.
There's a lot of support there,
so they're kind of managing the day to day produce oil stuff and I can kind of
focus on the creative stuff produced Soria it's,
it's tough.
It's a hard job.
I'm not great at it.
I'm very good.
And I like the creative producing.
I want to,
I want to talk to writers,
I want to talk to actors.
I want to like character develop story,
our character arc.
I want to do that kind of producing and then my partner has to do all the
horrible stuff.
Well,
it seems like the best fit for me.
Yeah.
Um,
I want to,
uh,
I want to quote you for a second.
Yes.
Yet you said,
I've never gotten to do a romantic comedy.
Like most of the girls,
maybe because I'm fit,
people assume I'm not funny.
I said that
definitely,
like I said,
that's what the internet said.
I Google their net is always right.
I googled it.
Okay,
let's go with it.
Did you say,
okay,
so fit,
therefore I'm not funny.
Okay.
Oh,
don't repeat it please.
God,
I beg you anyway.
Let's keep going.
I know where you're going with this.
So this is,
yeah,
this is a very dramatic role.
Yeah.
I'm very serious.
And chainsaw massacre a seventh heaven.
You were in the,
the third blade with Wesley Snipes.
Yeah.
Um,
all of these are not funny roles.
You're right.
They're not even air quotes but funny roles.
Um,
they're actually not funny.
What do the role seek you out or do you seek out the roles?
Now this is a very good question because when you put it on paper like that,
I'm like,
what is wrong with me?
Why am I wanting to scare everybody and like be serious all the time?
Cause I'm really not that serious of a person actually.
So I don't know.
I'm,
I think,
I think it must be a little bit of both somehow.
I mean,
I really like,
you know what it is I like,
I like to be scared and I like to watch dramatic things.
I think maybe that's what it is.
So if there's a cool piece of material,
I'm just looking at it as if it's something that I would watch and then maybe I
would want to be in it or something.
Maybe not.
So you don't watch anything funny.
Well,
see that's not true either.
I mean,
I watch,
I watch more dramatic stuff,
but I of course I love to laugh.
Right.
I'm getting really insecure about this,
about myself.
I think I need to change something about my life.
All right.
Then I will co wrote a comedy and you will please.
Thank you.
Okay.
You'll be first on my list.
I hope so.
Huh.
Um,
so there's a tie and obviously with the book that is sitting here with your
picture on it.
Uh Oh yeah.
Have you seen this?
I have seen that,
yes.
I think that looks pretty cool.
I never thought I'd be in the cover of a book before.
Yeah.
Well I mean it's a little random.
No.
Well,
if you're really cool something based on a book that,
yeah,
I know.
But do you see people on books very often?
I don't.
Are you on a book?
Don't mean no.
Well,
I'm on a book,
so yeah,
I'm on like six bucks.
Um,
books about how to interview badly.
this is going quite well.
Oh,
thank you.
I don't know.
All right.
Maybe I'm off.
We've got a few lols so we're okay.
Uh,
the,
the filming or the,
the series takes place in upstate New York,
right?
Did you film there or where did you film all the different things?
Well,
we filmed,
oh,
okay.
We filmed our pilot in Charleston,
South Carolina,
which was so cool.
What a great place to,
to spend some time.
But we did that because we could sort of fake upstate New York at that time.
I mean,
you know,
listen to fully,
just very different,
but we managed to,
to fake it a little bit.
We were dealing with a time in the year issue and obviously you could see I was
in the water a decent amount and we were really worried about being upstate New
York.
I think it was October,
it was October,
we were filming.
So we thought,
hmm,
that's a little tricky.
A little dicey.
You never know.
It could be like iced over and frozens possible.
Um,
so we filmed the pilot there and then everything else,
we're still filming.
I have to go back to work tomorrow.
I have a day off today.
Hang out with you guys.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah,
this is your day off.
This is my day.
Um,
but I am not like crying and sad and miserable,
which is basically what I am a lot on this show,
so we're not doing,
I know it's true.
Yeah.
I'm getting ahead of myself.
Um,
so the rest of the episodes,
the rest of the seven will be shot here and we are,
we're working here in a lot of places,
upstate kind of Nyack area and,
and other surrounding areas.
So the,
the,
the city that the story is set in totally fictional.
No,
it's not totally fictional.
I think it's,
it's,
it could be like new Paltz is that fictional place.
I didn't,
I thought that was an actual real,
yeah.
Israel.
Okay.
You'll look at me like I'm crazy.
I've never heard of it.
Okay.
Yeah.
So that I look at it like I've never heard
it's,
it's supposed to be a place like new Paltz write up,
little upstate,
um,
small,
smallish.
I've never actually spend much time in that particular place.
So I don't know how small,
I don't want to talk out of turn here,
but kind of like every,
every,
every kind of a place.
Do you know what I mean?
Right,
right.
Like,
could,
could find this sort of town across the country.
It's interesting you said every place kind of a place,
but there are,
I feel like there are specific characters,
types of people that we see in here that exists in all of these,
every places like the crazy religious family and then the,
the,
you know,
your small town shop owners and whatnot.
So,
yeah,
I think it,
uh,
was,
was it a conscious decision to kind of set that to set the story in a place like
this to enhance the character or enhance the story or does one kind of a big at
the other?
That's a good question.
I believe,
I mean since this is a German book,
I a German writer,
uh,
initiative originally I fee,
I know it was set in Germany somewhere.
So I think we were trying to find a place that would serve as um,
uh,
the right town in the states for,
I dunno,
kind of like a place that could,
could have,
have a character of its own in a sense.
I feel like upstate kind of has that feeling of,
I don't know it,
there could be a lot of bubbling simmering things going on underneath,
which is sort of what we're talking about in this show a little bit,
you know?
Yeah.
Kind of like from the outside,
things are looking one way and then when you look a little deeper you seeing
something else.
I'm not trying to like bag on upstate.
Like there's some weird stuff going on there,
but that's true everywhere.
This idea of like presenting ourselves in a certain way and maybe that's not
necessarily a hundred percent true.
I totally agree with you.
I grew up in a small town in North Carolina,
so same mountain chain,
same culture,
just different,
different areas.
But yeah,
I totally agree with that.
Um,
so as executive producer,
did you help with any of the casting of the show or did you have any yes,
yes.
All of it.
We have been,
it's actually been an amazing experience and because I am usually on the other
side of it and you know,
I'm the one putting myself on tape or going in for the audition and sending,
you know,
having to send these tapes that you make at home that you like so embarrassed
about,
you're like,
oh this is horrible and the lighting's bad.
You're by yourself reading with,
you know,
somebody who can't read lines cause it's like your mom and the whole thing's
bad.
I have,
I've such like,
I have like such a love and respect for the people that,
you know,
have,
have audition for this show because of being on the other side.
It's just so intense.
I know what they're going through and I know how hard it is and that process has
been super cool.
You know,
I have a,
I just have a different take on,
on,
on a reading,
uh,
on the creative,
you know,
performance part of it than say some of my other producers or,
or even,
you know,
even our creator or our director at the time.
So it's,
it's been,
it's been amazing and I love being part of,
of that,
that part of it.
Yeah.
I guess now that you've seen what it's like on the other side,
has that changed how you're approaching new roles?
Are you even entertaining new roles yet or you're still working on finishing
this one?
Um,
I've read a couple of things,
but now that we're sort of in the last stretch of,
of the filming it is,
I mean it's like a cluster some days,
you know,
it's just,
everything's kind of piling on top of itself.
So I haven't really looked at anything seriously are,
there hasn't really been anything that I'm really,
really excited about.
So I've been focused,
no comedies,
no,
not on purpose though.
Right.
But the whole,
you know,
I think it's changed my perspective.
It just made me mad,
you know,
I'm like,
Ugh,
I don't want to do another audition because they're going to do what I'm doing
when I'm watching the audition tape is like,
oh,
this person is so good.
But you know,
cause we need like no buts.
Just hire me.
I'm great.
Trust me,
I can for you.
Okay.
Huh.
Huh,
Huh?
With that note,
we have mics in the aisles.
If any of you have questions for Jessica,
um,
line up and we can get to those.
Um,
you are a mom now.
Congratulations.
Thanks.
Yes,
he's Silas is two and a half,
almost two and a half.
Yeah.
Oh,
that's soon.
Some Janine,
great age isn't it?
It isn't.
It isn't it?
Yeah,
it could be really great and then it can be really terrible.
I got a two and a half year old.
I feel you.
Has being a mother in real life,
uh,
influenced how you've approached the character of Cora here in the center?
I think,
I think just inherently,
yes,
it has to because now I want to have an actual understanding of what that
relationship is,
you know,
if I was by if I didn't have a kid,
yeah,
of course you can,
you know,
evoke as many feelings as you can possibly,
build up in your body to understand what that feels like.
But it will never compare to the actual feeling of it and the actual doing of
it,
you know,
being a parent every day and um,
it's,
it's the,
it's like the best research ever just having to,
you know,
exist with your kid every day to,
to understand what it would be like,
you know,
like if a person does this kind of a thing that she does the trickle effect for
her life specifically.
Like,
what happens to her and her family and her kid and her relationship.
Does she ever see him again?
Who you,
you know,
like this,
these are big questions when somebody does something like this.
So I have a lot of emotions that I,
that come up for me when we shoot stuff and when we,
um,
you know,
deal with the mom child relationship because like if I couldn't see my kid
again,
I would like,
I would,
I would not make it,
you know,
I would just die on the floor right here,
right?
Yeah.
Here you go.
No question over here.
I just go.
Um,
it looks great.
Congratulations.
It looks really awesome.
I'm really excited to watch it.
Um,
so you're here a how a youtube and obviously there's a lot of places where
people can get kind of amazing premium content like this.
Um,
how do you either as an actress or executive producer,
you've been in the business a long time.
How do you see marketing different nowadays than it's been in the past?
Because people have so many options.
Love your thoughts,
either as an actress or executive producer.
I mean,
you're right,
it's changed so much.
It's,
I think when I was younger and we,
we really didn't have this kind of access or these kinds of platforms,
it just,
every,
everything was dependent on,
you know,
the,
the studio or the network and they did everything.
And you didn't do anything as a,
as one of the creative people,
you just kind of did what they told you to do and you know,
you would go do like an interview or are you doing magazine cover?
And like that was kind of it,
it was very simple.
And now I feel so much more involved.
I'm,
I'm talking to USA all the time.
We're like collaborating on,
well,
what am I going to post?
What are you guys posting?
Um,
how can we,
how can we push the marketing campaign?
You know,
with my personal help with my personal platforms,
with their platforms,
it's,
so,
um,
it's,
it's very much more of like a community thing now.
And it's,
it's really nice because you feel like you have a hand in helping it get out
there.
And I guess that means you also have a hand and if it fails,
then nobody cared.
And all this stuff you did like it didn't matter,
but at least you're part of it.
I feel much more a part of it from the creative side.
And I guess from the pre predatorial standpoint,
as much help as you can get,
you know,
to get the word out for people to be talking about your material,
talking about your show is only helpful.
So it's just,
it's been nothing but positive I think when it comes to marketing in my
experience.
Great.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Gotcha.
Hi there.
Hi.
This is something I've always wanted her about what exactly,
how does it,
when you're,
are you reading something at home and you're just shoot yourself,
I really like this.
I'm gonna make this into a movie or what exactly is the process that you get in
a source material when it does come from a book or something like that to be
turned into,
you know,
television show or a movie.
How did that work with this book and how does that work in general?
Um,
bless you have for this book.
I,
um,
I just started reading,
you know,
and like a couple couple chapters in,
I,
I just was really interested and really intrigued and then I,
you know,
continued on and kept calling my partner Michelle and saying,
have you made it to chapter whatever yet you got to get there.
It's really good.
Whoa.
This went in a direction.
I didn't think that it was going to go in.
And this is a different,
um,
a different experience because the material was already owned by UCP,
so it wasn't,
it wasn't a situation where I had to reach out and try to get the rights,
which we've done multiple times before.
Um,
honestly I will look at a cover of something and go,
this looks interesting.
Somebody called about the rights like right,
like that fast because the rights are just gone.
Especially if it has any sort of notoriety in the literary world or anything at
all.
If it's on anybody's list,
if it's on Oprah's list,
forget it.
It's gone.
Literally,
I want to be like talking to authors who haven't published yet.
When their books are,
you know,
on the,
on the way,
you know,
in their third,
fourth,
fifth,
whatever drafts.
That's when you want to be snatching up material.
So this was a little bit different because a UCP was bringing it to me.
I had the opportunity to jump on board,
you know right away,
which I did.
And yeah,
it's just about your interest.
Like do you like it?
Is it fun?
Is it,
is it,
is there a good character here?
Is it interesting?
Is it compelling?
It's kind of as simple as that,
at least in my experience.
Thank you.
GCP is universal cable productions,
is that what it is?
Yes.
Yep.
Right over here.
Sorry,
I should have said that.
Right.
As a proud owner of blade trinity,
I feel like that actually qualifies as a comedy at some points.
Yeah.
Thank you very much.
As Jason was sort of alluding to before about this new era of marketing and
distribution and access points and TV ratings might not be the best way to
qualify.
What is a good show and a bad show or success?
We'll show.
Not One.
I'm curious how as your first foray into TV,
um,
second I guess seventh heaven counts.
Thank you.
Also,
sometimes the comedy
don't look at me.
How are you looking to gauge success for the sinner in this new world of,
of content?
This is a very good question.
Okay.
I'm nervous about this because I'm a kind of a viewer that likes to um,
binge.
So I want my stuff when I want it as opposed to having to wait week,
week by week.
So I don't know how to gauge it honestly.
Um,
I don't know what to expect for Wednesday night and if we have kind of not so
good numbers,
like you said,
it doesn't necessarily mean that the show would not have a good viewership or
following and may not necessarily mean that we won't have a second season,
but I still have a bit of an old school feeling about it,
you know,
like,
oh well if we don't get good numbers then I guess we'll probably get canceled or
we won't,
we won't get a second season.
I think we have to wait.
I think,
I think we're going to have to wait when,
when it can be streamed to really see what the legs of the show,
what's going to be.
Um,
because I don't know.
I don't,
I want it when I want it,
like most people do.
So it'll be really interesting to see what happens.
Um,
I think I have to remember to not just take the numbers on Wednesday,
you know,
as,
as truth.
And that's it.
Because you're right,
it's so different now.
You Watch yourself,
you know why from Nielsen numbers.
I don't know.
I mean,
I'll turn my television on for sure.
I,
I don't know.
I haven't figured that out yet.
I,
I see my films,
but I've watched this so many times.
I've seen these cuts a lot.
Um,
I don't think I'm going to have like a viewing party or anything.
I know.
I don't know.
I haven't really thought about it.
Interesting.
I don't,
yeah,
uh,
I don't know if that would be weird or not to watch yourself on TV.
Maybe the first time you've,
I'm sure you've binged all up seventh heaven,
but you're probably all of it.
Oh yeah.
I just constantly would go back to the beginning.
And
one more question here.
I just got,
I was wondering who's like your favorite actor you've worked with?
Favorite actor?
Yeah.
Ah,
that's a good question.
I've,
I've husband,
have we worked together in that capacity?
Have we?
Oh,
no,
I don't think so.
Yeah,
he's really good though.
Um,
I've had the pleasure of working with a lot of great people.
I think I've,
you know,
Bill,
Bill Pullman and Chris and everyone we're working with.
This has been amazing.
So much fun.
I also really loved working on the illusionist with Ed Norton and Paul Giamatti,
those two guys.
I mean,
they just blew me away.
They're so nice and so talented.
I mean,
everyone I've worked with has been amazing in their own right.
But I would say those,
maybe those two I really enjoyed.
Awesome.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Cool.
Hey.
Um,
so you know how when you base something off a book like beat a movie or a TV
show,
innovative leaders are going to be some changes.
Um,
like usually the plug is different or something's are being caught or somethings
are being added.
And so I guess two questions.
Firstly,
how loosely d to base it off of the book.
Like is it very accurate or did you like get a lot of like creative license with
it?
And secondly,
um,
how do you make those decisions?
Like how do you decide what is it and what is not and want to add?
Right.
Good questions.
Um,
so we,
we stick pretty closely to kind of the main real threads of this book.
This book kind of lives in two worlds,
a present time and a past.
And so there's these threads that were kind of following and we take some
creative liberties I think with mainly with the characters.
I don't even know if you'd call it creative liberties.
And we just developed and developed them in a different way,
maybe a little bit more thoroughly in some ways a little bit broader.
And other ways,
you know,
took some like really acute ideas of these characters and expanded it a little
bit,
but we stick pretty closely to the main big plot points.
For example,
the Ambrose character bill Pullman's character,
he's much different in our show then he is in the book,
um,
Cora,
right in that way or did bill choose to take it that we,
we wrote it.
Yeah.
That way there
I think me and my producers and our creator,
Derek Simons,
who's an incredible writer and developer,
he really saw that that Ambrose character needed,
needed more behind it.
You know,
needed,
needed to like really flush out this person for television,
you know,
so he took that,
he took that liberty and change that character.
Um,
the second question was,
can you,
can you remind me,
how'd you go about making the decision making the decisions?
You know,
that's a tough one because you obviously want to keep the skeleton and the,
the real like the,
the flavor,
the language of the book.
Because you know,
you're,
you're optioning this material for a reason,
but the form,
the formats are so different,
right?
You can sit and read,
you know,
you could read this book for days and days and days and just like slowly get
chunks.
It'd be very happy with it.
Whereas what we're trying to do is keep,
keep your attention,
keep an audience's interest for,
I think it's what,
42 minutes with commercials,
Short,
attentive,
attention spans.
You know,
we,
we have to kind of drop little nuggets along the way to keep you interested and
keep you going.
So we really have to cut things and add things to keep that in mind,
to keep the suspense moving.
Whereas,
you know,
you could read a book and it's just like interesting and romantic and
atmospheric,
but like nothing really happens for a while and you're cool with it if that
doesn't work obviously and television.
But the main person who is making these decisions is,
is Derrick r r writer,
creator.
And we are trusting him to know that this is the best way to handle,
you know,
all of these interweaving storylines,
arcs,
um,
themes past,
present time.
You know,
it was,
it's very complicated what we've been having to do and how he's been doing it as
a and quite,
uh,
quite an amazing feat.
So hopefully you will agree.
Cool.
We are actually short on time.
I know you're going,
so I'm going to use your quick question over here.
Good time for one more,
hopefully.
Okay.
Yeah.
Uh,
so we already started to touch on this briefly.
Um,
are you ever sitting at your house looking at as source material and you and
Justin just like look at each other and you're like,
hey,
we should do this together or have you talked about kind of your lives like we
do this or hey,
I'd love for you to kill me in this.
He would probably love that.
Yes,
all the time.
All the time.
We are looking,
you know,
I'm reading something going,
you should read this.
There's a really interesting character in here for you or we should,
yes,
we should try to do something together.
What would it be?
I always say to him that it would be fun to do something where we're like not
playing lovers or not playing like married people,
you know,
do something completely.
I don't know.
Something,
not that.
I don't know what that would mean.
Comedian assassins.
Yeah,
there you go.
That would be fun.
Yeah.
So yeah,
we're always looking for that right thing because you know,
why not?
Why not work with your best friend,
partner,
person.
Um,
if you can,
but I really didn't give to be careful because you know,
we've all seen this go terribly wrong.
You know what I'm talking about?
There's a few of them that I'm talking about,
so it's like,
yeah,
it's a delicate
balance of finding the right thing and it being at the right time of your lives.
And I don't know,
we haven't found it yet,
but I hope,
I hope so.
I hope we can.
I'd love to work with him.
Actually.
You know what?
We talk a lot about him directing me in something.
Hmm.
Which I think would be really cool because he's,
he's directed a few things,
like little things,
commercials and different things.
And he has a,
basically does a lot with his own videos and stuff like that.
But I think,
I really think he'd be an amazing film filmmaker.
So I,
I'd love for him to direct me in something.
So now it's out there and you better do it because I'm the boss of him.
All right.
Uh,
so cool.
We have this little android for you is thank you for coming.
That's a toxic.
I do want to go see a watch the sinner this Wednesday,
August 2nd on USA and help me.
Thank you Jessica Biel for coming in.
Thank you guys.
You.